hello uh
so uh my name is Mark lutter I'm the
founder and chairman of the charter
cities Institute uh little bit about my
background I come from a distinguished
line of bureaucrats my dad worked for
the FDA which I know is a fan favorite
here uh my mom worked for the uh
Pan-American and branch of the World
Health Organization and in my kind of
teenage rebellion and now middle-age
kind of adult Rebellion I decided to
build better
institutions so I did my PhD at George
Mason in economics and that's kind of
inform my worldview thinking about what
are the economic levers of governance
what leads to economic growth over the
long
term and why that
matters and the kind of conclusion was
Charter cities right governance matters
if a country is well governed it will
tend to do relatively well if a country
is poorly governed it will tend to do
relatively poorly the challenge often is
how do you change government on a
national level because you have a lot of
special interest groups governments are
tend to be slow to reform and so instead
we focus on how do you change it on a
city level right so what is a charter
City a charter city is a new city with
better laws the city park is important
because you need a sufficient number of
people to have a glomeration to have the
benefits of living together right we
heard some presentations earlier about
building communities and these
communities tend to be much easier to
build when you're already in mesed in a
large Urban environment with amenities
with a number of people who might share
those
interests second is kind of the better
laws right so think about a charter city
as kind of a supercharged special
economic zone right Authority is
delegated from the government to the
zone that allows them to have easier
building processes A Better Business
environment uh perhaps better
immigration rules that allow you to be
more competitive on the city level and
this is multiuse not just a single
industry so why are Charter cities
important there are a rule for changing
rules right Humanity has developed some
good rules for governing ourselves but
there are probably better rules out
there and often times you don't want to
implement these rules at a national
level because you're not quite sure how
they'll work but if you implement them
at a local level for example China right
their economic growth was driven by
special economics zones and urbanization
the special economic zone started in
shenzen they pioneered labor markets
land markets uh financial markets and
those spread throughout the rest of
China once they could test those reforms
within the Chinese system they knew they
would work they'd spread them to other
coastal cities eventually throughout
China and that led to 10% annual growth
for almost 40 years leading China to be
a global superpower today so like
generally framing this can help
accelerate growth in Emerging Markets as
well as kind of accelerate technological
innovation in advanced
economies so how do we think about a
history of the space right we have Paul
RoR who's a Nobel Laur in economics
currently at NYU he gave a TED Talk in
2009 on Charter cities and his version
of Charter cities is a little bit
different from the one that I advocate
but what he advocated was a high income
country for example Canada administer a
city in a low-income country for example
uh B right where the high income country
has good institutions they can sign a
treaty with the lower income country ad
Minister the city this got a lot of push
back because a lot of low-income
countries thought hey this smells a bit
like colonialism he tried in uh
Madagascar and then in Honduras and
actually the current legislation in
Honduras that prospera and others are
operating in is in part a descendant
from Paul romer's uh involvement in that
country at the same time you had the
seaing movement right I think that seing
Institute launched in 2008 where Paul
RoR focused primarily on how do you make
poor countries lus poor seing focused on
how do we accelerate technological
innovation how do we get the smartest
people together how do we kind of
improve Cutting Edge
institutions and then what's happened
recently is that kind of network states
have emerged as an idea as a concept and
one of the most interesting examples of
this is this event as well as zalu which
vitalic buterin spoke at previously uh
spoke at a few hours ago and so I helped
organize the new cities and network
States track at zalu but it demonstrated
it's possible to bring together a few
hundred people for several months that
can seed new communities and eventually
turn into new cities right it's
demonstrated a function of demand
aggregation to bring these communities
together to help instantiate kind of the
physical infrastructure that allows them
toow over
time so how do we think about Charter
cities today right there's several
historic examples and a lot of this
depends on how strictly or Loosely you
define Charter cities with a somewhat
loose definition you can include
Singapore Dubai shenzen Hong Kong all of
these are cities that have varying
degrees of autonomy right Singapore is a
separate country Hong Kong was British
then even under Chinese there was one
country to system though in the last few
years it's kind of been collapsed a
little bit with the passage of the
National Security Law you have shenzen
which is frequently called a special
economic zone however when it was
implemented uh if you read some of the
early legislation they basically had a
full set of Rights except for things
like uh uh rail systems and post office
but beyond that they could experiment
with labor law with land law with which
with all of these things that otherwise
in China were effectively illegal to do
um and then Dubai right it's part of the
United Arab Emirates and then they have
a series of special economic zones of
which the Dubai International Financial
Center is one of the best known where
they brought in common law judges to
create a financial center that could
compete with uh Global Financial Centers
right and if you think about current
projects in Honduras you have Prospero
which present presented earlier you have
you have Su you have prais which
also presented earlier uh Bravo cities
is my company I'll talk about a little
bit at the end uh still uh a little bit
in stealth you have neam which is a very
large Sai new city project that the Sai
government has committed a half billion
dollars to uh they're focusing on one
breathtaking infrastructure and then
two on uh uh an improved legal
environment to help attract businesses
and residents to to relocate
there so I founded the charter cities
Institute about six years ago and we're
a nonprofit for building the ecosystem
for Charter cities and so how do we
think about this one is building a city
right requires a
population and so so thinking about
where that population comes from we see
as critical to understanding what the
Dynamics of the city look like broadly
defined they kind of two global
migration patterns that can be tapped
into for cities defined as hundreds of
thousands to millions of residents one
is a global South to Global North
migration right A lot of people want to
be in the US want to be in Europe and
two is a rural to Urban migration in the
global
South and
so I started as a nonprofit because
building a city has very long time
Horizons there's a number of
stakeholders involved I attended a
conference in Kazakhstan that was
helping to plan a new city that had
several distinguished urban planners
from MIT and they for example were
unaware that zoning and land used
increased housing prices and so I
realized that one there are new cities
being built and two the advisers they
are hiring for these new cities often
times had Prestige but did not actually
have a functional understanding of how
the cities operated how to sequence
things how to scale them into kind of a
functional uh Urban aeration Urban
environment right and so what do we do
the charter cities Institute we do
events we're hosting an event in Rwanda
in kagali in about three weeks bringing
together a lot of the stakeholders in
the Africa ecosystem where we focus we
do research thinking about all right
what are the key ingredients that go
into a new city how do you partner with
these uh uh different stakeholders and
then we out those Partnerships right who
are the funders how do you talk to
governments we don't see these as
antagonistic to governments but a way
for governments to really help achieve
their
aims
so let me run through this quickly I'm
running out of time here uh one of the
key challenges is right where is land if
you want to do a city you need tens of
thousands of acres of land how do you
amalgamate that Land close enough to
existing infrastructure that you can
piggy back off the existing
infrastructure how do you work with
governments most governments will have
five or 10e plans right where they will
say we want to create X number of
housing units y number of jobs Z number
of uh schools and then you frame your
project as a solution to the challenges
the governments are already concerned
about how do you finance the development
right different areas have different
Financial mechanisms for large
infrastructure projects but Charters are
effectively large infrastructure
projects and you need to do that all
right spaces are validated when they get
large exits when they are able to
achieve that we heard from some of these
early projects and we can see a lot of
momentum in this room but I think
catalyzing that momentum really kind of
building it up requires uh uh projects
that that that launch with tens of
thousands of residents and hopefully in
the next five years we can get there so
Bravo cities we're partnering with the
zanzibari government and a local
developer this is a render of the
development in
Zanzibar and we're basically taking a
low friction strategy right the existing
development has 600 units it's 30
minutes south of Stonetown the main city
20 minutes south of the airport we want
to build the knowledge Center of East
Africa suck all the brains out of East
Africa put them in uh in fumba fumba
Peninsula fumba city which is what we're
building and the government has a
special economic zone we're partnering
with them to improve the operations of
that zone so we can expedite investment
attract more businesses attract more
companies make sure the developers have
the appropriate infrastructure to scale
and so lastly if you want to learn more
right the website is Charter cities
institute.org uh Twitter cc. City my
Twitter is markl uh my email we have the
charter cities podcast Africa's new city
Summit feel free to find me later thank
you very much for
listening